[Music]
and they get to go to their jobs
we just stay home and
supposed to be enough
[Music]
you always want more oh you do candy
whatever you have you always want more
I'm not gonna pause for it
even nature
to go for something with a little thrill
at the risk of falling oh we okay
are you sure yeah
would you be interested in having an
affair
[Music]
we can never allow Betty or Pat to get
hurt
never ever
[Applause]
I would love to have you and Pat over a
few months
need
to be careful
[Applause]
[Music]
Eddie Betty
and he's dead
[Music]
I say she was murdered with an ax an ax
more than likely that Igor was murdered
by someone she knew did you kill your
wife no
I did have an affair with Candy
Montgomery
are you all right
yeah wouldn't that be all right
you just chopped and chopped and chopped
I didn't do it
I think he did you're wrong
it's Texas I hope it might be able to
forgive murder adultery not so much the
jury needs to see you as human
and the truth has a way of coming out
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you